mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
the diagram illustrates a net of an
unfolded rectangular box the diagram has
dimensions of 13 10 and 34 as shown
what is the volume of the rectangular
box
i thank ketechie for suggesting this
problem
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem we will
get started by color coding opposite
faces of the rectangular box
we will then fold these faces together
to create a rectangular box
this three-dimensional shape has a
length equal to l a width equal to w and
a height equal to h
we will then unfold the faces to get
back to the net
we can then label the lengths on this
diagram
we will label some sides as l
other sides as h and this remaining side
is w from here we have 34 is equal to 2l
plus 2h
we then have 13 is equal to w plus l
and finally we have 10 is equal to w
plus h
we have a system of three equations for
three variables
we'll get started by dividing the first
equation by two
we'll then subtract the third equation
from the second equation and we get
three is equal to l minus h
we'll add these two resultant equations
together and eliminate the h variable so
we get the 20 is equal to 2l
this means l is equal to 10.
we can substitute into the second
equation to solve that w is equal to 3
we can then substitute into the third
equation to solve that h is equal to 7.
we can then use these dimensions to
solve for the volume of the rectangular
box which is equal to l times w times h
and that's equal to 210
this was quite a challenging problem but
with a little bit of inside and outside
the box thinking we were able to solve
it quite routinely
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you